traffic is moving once again on the u.s
95 after a major crash closed it for
much of the day a tanker carrying gas
overturned in a collision near the
valley view exit 8 news now joe muller
is live there at the scene and joe i was
out there this morning i got caught in
the mess it was a real nightmare but i
understand clearing the scene was quite
the process
well christian that makes two of us
caught in the mess traffic was a bit of
a nightmare for people here on the 95.
the good news is traffic is moving in
both directions but the bad news here's
a live look bad news is that there's
still a lane closure on the northbound
lanes here at valley view the exit here
this all reopened both ways around two
o'clock this all happened before five
when a bmw and truck carrying thousands
of gallons of fuel crashed on the
northbound side of the 95 north of the
valley view exit around 100 gallons of
fuel spilled the rest of the gas had to
be transferred to another tanker truck
crews then flipped the tanker and towed
it away with with several crews here to
help and it took several hours luckily
no one was hospitalized or suffered
major injuries people were waiting an
hour to get just a few miles i knew it
was going to be all day especially with
an overturned taker and the oil is
seeping out so i figured it was going to
be
something it was something major going
on
the northbound lanes were closed until
around two o'clock this afternoon now
back out here live again there is a lane
closure still on the northbound lane
you're taking a look there it seems that
crews are attending to that light pole
there but we have been talking to
several people who were
stopping by the location we were at just
to see what is going on many are saying
they're happy to see the traffic is
going once again here just in time
before people start to get off work here
very shortly reporting live joe mullen 8
news now